the city of Chicago has a food problem
grocery chains don't want to open new
stores there and the stores that are
there are about to close
the problem has been brewing for a while
but it's gotten much worse in recent
years for instance the number of Chicago
residents living more than a mile away
from a grocery store has jumped by 63
percent since 2013.
the Liberals are blaming the growing
food desert on The Usual Suspects racism
discrimination inequality
in fact the problem is crime
shoplifting and vandalism as one Walmart
representative told the New York Post
quote collectively our Chicago stores
have not been profitable since we opened
the first one nearly 17 years ago
so what is Chicago going to do about it
are Chicago officials going to arrest
the criminals
no of course not
they're going to open government-owned
grocery stores instead
that is the proposal by Chicago mayor
Brandon Johnson to address the food
desert crisis
now you might be thinking that it's
crazy to turn America's Second City into
a Midwestern Soviet state when you could
just as easily keep ShopRite and Whole
Foods and all the rest of them by simply
arresting the criminals
but that reaction supposes that Chicago
officials don't want to turn the city
into a Soviet state
that reaction supposes that the liberal
ruling class considers the criminals a
problem when in fact they are a part of
the Liberals solution
a term that has gained traction recently
for this situation is anarcho-tyranny a
paradoxical state in which the
government meticulously oppressively
regulates citizens lives while at the
same time refusing to enforce basic
aspects of the law
the government sends a right-wing
private citizen to prison for 10 years
for tweeting some run-of-the-mill memes
in the case of Douglas Mackey
and at the same time lets BLM and antifa
off the hook for looting killing and
burning the country down for eight
months then the state uses the chaos
that it created to justify taking even
more power
pretty soon the government is running
the grocery stores
you and I look at Chicago as a failed
City
the left looks at it as a massive
success
expect a similar program to come to a
city near you if it hasn't already I'm
Michael knowlesis the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by good ranchers get Greg
meat at a secure price and 25 bucks off
your order with my code Knowles Canon
wlas go to goodranchors.com use my code
Knowles today
Louis CK has the perfect liberal
argument on immigration which is of
course open borders and the reason for
the open borders is that America
shouldn't be so nice we'll get to that
argument in just one second it's not
just Louis it's very very typical first
though
we turn
to the subject of crime and Law and
Order to attorney general Merrick
Garland who insists that contrary to
whatever you might think
America has only one system of justice
for everybody that means we apply the
same laws to everyone there is not one
set of laws for the powerful and another
for the powerless one for the rich and
another for the poor one for Democrats
and another for Republicans or different
rules depending upon one's race or
ethnicity or religion
I'm gonna give him credit for one thing
which is that he was able to say that
with a straight face
that is amazing the example we just
cited Douglas Mackey this random private
citizen who happens to be right wing
tweets out a meme a joke meme about the
election and it's an old joke by the way
it's the old joke where if you're if
you're on a campaign you're going door
to door you're talking to voters they
say when's the election and you say are
you a Republican or a Democrat if you're
a republican the election's on Tuesday
if you're a Democrat the election's on
Wednesday ha ha ha Douglas Mackey that
was the meme you tweeted out hey
Democrats tweet your vote please don't
show up to the polls just tweet your
vote they're going to send him to prison
for 10 years for that
meanwhile BLM murders people Burns
cities to the ground loots steals Nike
shoes creates Havoc for eight months
many if not most of them are let off
without so much as a slap on the wrist
but we have one system of justice for
everybody don't we
Donald Trump
makes a phone call to Ukraine and gets
impeached for it now he's been indicted
four times as the former president
leader of the opposition
Joe Biden brags on camera about firing a
prosecutor in Ukraine who was
investigating his son's crooked business
deals threatening to withhold a billion
dollars in Aid Joe Biden is caught on
camera admitting to doing a more
egregious version of the thing for which
they impeach Donald Trump
no problem no investigation no big deal
and Merrick Garland says one set of
rules for everybody it's it's not a
two-tier justice system what are you
talking about
Sam Brinton who is the kleptomaniac
former nuclear waste desire for the
Biden Administration try to say that
five times fast Sam Brinton was caught
on camera in multiple cities stealing
women's luggage and then he was caught
on camera wearing the women's clothing
from the luggage afterward and the
jewelry we're talking not just about a
hundred dollar dress from Kohl's we're
talking about thousands and thousands of
dollars worth of clothing and jewelry
which in a normal society would have
probably raised some eyebrows on account
of it was women's clothing and he is a
man but in our society we we don't we
don't even notice it anymore we just
sort of shrug and move along
but Sam brenta was caught dead to rights
and he gets arrested finally and then
what happens
he's he's been let off the hook at every
turn
Sam Brinson has already avoided jail
time twice
in Minnesota and Nevada for doing this
meanwhile the horn hat guy who peaceably
walks around the capitol on January 6th
the worst day in the history of this or
any Republic he's escorted by police
he's getting a private tour from the
Capitol Hill Police that guy goes to
prison for 41 months
Sam Brenton weirdo criminal who is
caught on camera committing multiple
crimes oh he just goes free no big deal
and Garland says we have one set of
Justice in this country one set of rules
for everybody
he's a good actor Merrick Garland was
confronted about the fact that his
justice department his FBI was spying on
Catholic churches because his FBI
according to Memos that we saw not just
in one little office but in multiple
offices viewed traditional Catholics as
a terror threat an extremist threat in
America
here's Garland's reaction to being
called out for it attorney general
through the chair I ask you do you agree
that traditional Catholics are violent
extremists I have no idea what your what
the traditional means here yeah let me
just go to church may I answer your
question yes the idea that someone with
my family background
would discriminate against any religion
is so outrageous it's so absurds to
attorney general it was your FBI that
did this it was your FBI that was
sending and we have the memos
so you you notice already in that very
short clip Merit Garland tried two
different tactics
neither of which were particularly
convincing
first he's confronted with it say hey
um do you think traditional Catholics
are a terror threat he goes oh I don't
even know what that means what's a
traditional catholic huh this is what
they do on the word what's woke even
mean I don't even know what is antifa
like is that even an organization so he
tries to play dumb and then the
congressman the congressman Drew said
Congressman Andrew rather says
man it's in the memo I don't know you
your team defined it you tell me what
traditional Catholics mean and then then
Garland
flips the the strategy flips the tactic
to feigned outrage she says how dare you
even suggest
that somebody with my background and I
said what what background was Merrick
Garland ever a political prisoner or a
prisoner or persecuted for his religious
views that's like I look it up and all I
could find is he's Jewish and some of
his ancestors were persecuted which is a
safe bet if you're Jewish some of your
ancestors have been is it true for all
of us actually some of your ancestors
regardless of your racial or ethnic
background have been persecuted for some
aspect of their identity but
that's it there's nothing particular
there and he says could you imagine that
someone with my background would
persecute Catholics yeah I can imagine
because you did it bro you did it we saw
the memos and then you lied about it
keep going we're sending undercover
agents into Catholic churches both I am
the directors
of appalled have said that we were
appalled by that memo so then you agree
that they're not extremists you were
appalled by that memo are they
extremists or not attorney general I
think that are they extremists or not
attorney general
are they extremists or not I'm asking a
simple question say no if you think that
was wrong licks are not extremists no
was there anyone fired for Drafting and
circular circulating the anti-catholic
memo you have in front of you the
inspection divisions investigations tell
me yes or no please I don't know I have
no time I don't know the answer to that
I don't know the answer well then the
answer is no then the answer is no did
you uh are Catholics extremists no I
don't
I don't I mean I don't I don't wanna I
don't can you just answer the question
please are the people that you describe
in the Memoir traditional Catholics
extremists well what do you I I just
want to make the point that hey bro
answer the question and then he doesn't
answer the question he says Catholics
are not extremists but hold on you
defined
Catholics in a very particular way
you're talking about this subset that
you've defined in your memos of
traditional Catholics that's what we're
talking about so you might say no
Catholics like Stephen Colbert they're
not extremists
Catholics like Libs who
who don't take Doctrine and Dogma
totally seriously they're not extremists
but the ones in whom the Dogma lives
loudly to quote Dianne Feinstein
referring to Justice Amy Coney Barrett
oh they maybe they are extremists
I don't I would never do any such thing
your
doj your FBI did that and the key here
is not only did they do it and then they
denied it the head of the FBI and now
Mary Carlin they deny that they had the
Catholic memo
but then what did they say they said no
okay it was only in one field office but
then what did we find out we found out
that was a lie this was spread out among
multiple field offices
and they they lied about doing it they
lied about having done it and I promise
you they're going to lie about doing it
again
doesn't look good and when you want to
look good you got to check out geniusell
right now go to geniusell.com as you
might know we were all big fans of our
friends over at genucel in part because
of that founder who's a Coptic Christian
from Egypt who fled for the American
dream and largely just for how great the
product is don't take my word for it
Ella from Rockford says quote I have
both age and acne spots and this stuff
is actually fading both of them this
Serum is worth every penny Ella is
raving about the famous Dark Spot
Corrector from geniusell a must-have
after months of record heat and humidity
sunspots brown spots discoloration even
red inflamed patches all disappear in
front of your very eyes and here's the
geniusell amazing guarantee you will see
results on day one or your money back so
take advantage of geniusell's most
popular package which now includes the
Dark Spot Corrector plus the classic
genius cell eyes and puffiness treatment
and immediate effects all about seventy
seven zero percent off so that you can
try the best skincare in the world for
yourself completely risk-free it is very
simple
geniusell.com start looking years even
decades younger tomorrow say goodbye to
dark and liver spots bags and puffiness
under the eyes and crow's feet at
genucel.com Knowles
speaking of Law and Order Danny
Masterson who's the actor from That 70s
Show has been sentenced to 30 years to
life in prison
just a shockingly long prison sentence
uh he's 47 years old 30 years
plus 47 is not quite life in prison but
it's pretty close you're 77 when you get
out of there you're you're starting to
get up there when you're at 77.
so I read the allegations against him
and some people are saying they don't
even believe the allegations I basically
believe the women or at least I don't
see it much reason not to believe the
women broadly there are some
discrepancies I think between what they
alleged happened and what they are said
to have alleged happened back when it
happened and that's the real Point here
these crimes are alleged to have
happened
over 20 years ago
between 2001 and 2003
and so even if you like me give these
women the benefit of the doubt you don't
think that they're intentionally lying
you assume that virtually everyone in
Hollywood is a complete degenerate so
you assume that maybe Danny Masterson
did get up to this stuff in his past if
you're going to be all the way on the
side of the accusers here even still you
probably like me have a a sense that
this is not just that there's something
unjust about this sentence to Danny
Masterson in the year of Our Lord 2023
for 30 years in prison
for crimes that were alleged to have
happened over 20 years ago why
because we just feel that if
if a crime is committed against you you
should you should bring charges in a
timely manner that's why we have things
like statutes of limitations
but in this case there's no more statute
of limitations
why is that well because earlier this
year in January of 2023 La got rid of
the statute of limitations on rape
and L.A did that because of the metoo
movement and the time's up movement and
the facade of of girl power that the
sexual predators who run Los Angeles are
going to permit to exist for a little
bit of time before they go back to just
committing all of the same crimes that
they've been committing for for decades
for like a century now
that's what this is about and statutes
of limitations are good what the what
the me too times up people will say is
statutes of limitations are awful
because they silence the survivors of
sexual assault
statutes of limitations protect the
rights of everybody
the reason we have them is because 20
years later
evidence is going to be lost
evidence is going to be
suspect
memories are going to be foggy
I could sincerely believe that something
happened 20 years ago and sometimes I do
I'll say I know that this happened 20
years ago and then a friend of mine with
whom I had shared that experience will
say oh no Michael you just
misremembering that I mean that could
happen for something that happened five
or ten years ago people's memories are
not reliable especially over that long
period of time so that's the first issue
is the statute of limitations thing
because they just got rid of it
it just seems unjust even if Danny
Masterson did
precisely or even approximately what
they're accusing him of doing
just something seems wrong about that
system the second thing that this is
about is Scientology and one of the
reasons I believe the women or am
inclined to believe the women is
they did bring up this issue they did
bring up the crimes that allegedly
happened to them at the time but they
often didn't bring them up to law
enforcement or they didn't bring them up
directly to law enforcement they first
brought them up to Scientology because
they're all scientologists so they're
part of this cult and in this cult they
say don't ever go to the police about
anything just come to us which is
typical of Cults and and so these women
went to the Scientology ethics officers
and they said hey this guy raped me or
at the very least took advantage of me
or assaulted me or or something in
between and the ethics officer said yeah
well he's big and famous and important
so keep your mouth shut
and then they did
in some cases the women kept dating
Masterson they kept showing up to his
house they could so
that is not to say that he didn't commit
some egregious act against them or that
he didn't even commit a crime against
them but it is to say
you play stupid games you get stupid
prizes I guess if you decide to put your
your Justice your experience of Justice
into the hands of Ethics officers in a
cult well things probably aren't going
to work out in a very just way
if you continue to date someone after
you allege that they commit a terrible
crime against you people are going to
raise an eyebrow or maybe be a little
bit skeptical of your claims especially
if those claims come out decades later
and what is this really about it's not
even just about a Scientology it's about
Hollywood
this is how Hollywood operates
talked about this earlier in the week
Hollywood as a particularly egregious
example of the whole liberal
establishment operates in a way that is
kind of outside the law certainly
outside the moral laws often outside of
the civil law where you will be
encouraged to engage in really depraved
degrading things especially weird sex
stuff
and then
it just kind of goes away for a while
until it doesn't until it's convenient
until you're no longer useful to them or
until it's convenient to throw you under
the bus as an offering to the wolves and
that's what they'll do to you
nobody comes out of this
looking particularly good
uh I think that's generally true of
Hollywood and it's generally true of our
liberal culture but the problem here is
not going to be resolved just by
throwing Danny Masterson in prison
the problem is going to be resolved by
working and and correcting the entire
structures of Justice which have a
cultural component in the behavior and
Norms of Hollywood which have a
political component in the way that our
justice system works which is quite
unjust these days and It ultimately has
a theological component
in the Toleration of weirdo Cults like
this that victimize women
according to many many reports this is
this is what is inescapable
and it it's a problem that affects our
entire political order
all politics ultimately comes down to
religion Cardinal Manning put this well
he said all human conflict ultimately is
theological there never has been and
never can be a state that is divorced
from religion and Theological matters
because politics is about how we all
live together it has to do with laws and
ultimately laws come down to the moral
law and ultimately it comes down to the
question of the author of the moral law
politics has to do with people comes
down to the question of anthropology and
it has the comes down to the question of
who is man in whose image are we made
it it has to do with
ultimately
God because God is the author and
sustainer of all things and as long as
we keep
putting off the question and we say oh
God has nothing to do with Society we're
going to totally divorce Church from
State we don't more morality is just
socially constructed whatever then
weirdo Cults are going to continue to
prey on people and uh tyrannical
political leaders are going to continue
to flout
the the moral law and people are going
to continue to act in a way
it's very very
bad
it's not good people lose sleep over
this kind of stuff
when you want to get good sleep
you gotta check out Helix right now go
to Helix sleep.com Knowles with
everything going on in the world right
now you could really use a good night's
sleep that is why you need to check out
Helix mattress the Helix lineup offers
20 unique mattresses including the
award-winning Luxe collection the newly
released Helix Elite collection a
mattress designed for Big and Tall
sleepers and even a mattress made just
for kids I've had my Helix for years now
I absolutely love it night after night I
sleep like a comfy sweet little babe and
I want the same for you Helix has a
sleep quiz that matches your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress because why would you buy a
mattress made for someone else why do
you want to be in my mattress I'm a
married man and you need your own
mattress so go to helixsleep.com Knowles
take their two-minute sleep quiz to find
the perfect mattress for your body and
sleep type their flexible payment plans
make it so that a great night's sleep is
never far away Helix is offering 20 2-0
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners helix
sleep.com Knowles use code Helix partner
2020 this is their best offer yet won't
last long with Helix bittersleep starts
now
things continue to heat up in the new
daily wear plus series convicting a
murderer apparently Stephen Avery from
behind bars is directing his fans to
flood Rotten Tomatoes and give
convicting a murderer a bad review he
and his Facebook group Stephen Avery is
innocent are even referring to
convicting a murderer is garbage
as if the opinion of a convicted
murderer is of any value to anyone
nevertheless it seems we've made Steven
Avery and his fans very very angry which
means the series is doing its job and
we're about to Double Down
with episode 5 take a look
I think that the sheriff's department is
framing you because of the lawsuit right
that's what I think okay
James lank Andy Colburn they were
involved in the old case and here they
are again in this new case Steven Avery
is released from prison after being
wrongfully convicted Avery's attorneys
say those hardships are worth 36 million
dollars why were Manitowoc officers
involved when there was a 36 million
dollar pending lawsuit against them
Lincoln Colburn were villains the main
ones accused of planting evidence
were you asked to perform a thorough
search of this piece of furniture yes
suddenly I hear Lieutenant link say
there's key on the floor
I knew the significance of that and I
said you guys just up my case
new episodes are released every Thursday
exclusively DIY plus head over there now
to start the series if you've not
already if you're not a member go to
dailywireplus.com subscribe today
speaking of celebrities there's a
picture going viral of Donald Trump on
the campaign Trail signing a woman's
chest
I say chest because it's high up enough
that I don't it's not totally untoward
Trump also clearly has very very strong
autographed discipline because even as
he's signing this woman's chest his hand
is not touching his hand is you can see
a shadow on the lady's white tank top
and she's smiling she's so excited
people all around him in this bar
like their meeting
a celebrity which they are
and I mentioned the photo
to to
return to an objection that some
Republicans are making anti-trump
Republicans are making which is they'll
say yeah Trump's a celebrity but people
shouldn't care about celebrities this
election should not come down to
personality and charm and Charisma and
celebrity dammit that's not what this
election should be about
to which I respond
have you ever seen an election
have you ever
have you ever read about democracy
you ever met any people do you know how
people work what do you mean it
shouldn't be about celebrity you it is
it is it's Democratic politics man it's
a popularity contest
celebrity matters well it shouldn't
matter okay well the sun shouldn't shine
today okay but it does it's just a fact
of life this is how human beings operate
and it's especially how democracies
operate
so you can whine and cry about it pull
your hair out or you can
accept political reality as it is and
always will be and then try to work from
within it
this is just a fact
having lived in New York and La I've met
a number of celebrities and I've seen
celebrities up close and I have wondered
for many a year
why is it that celebrities have the
effect on people that they do
why is it that the line that got Trump
in the most trouble in 2016 the Access
Hollywood tape
said when you're when you're a celebrity
women let you do it they let you do
whatever you can do whatever you want
women let you do it and everyone was so
offended and clutch their pearls
and I thought
is a vulgar thing to say but it's
especially vulgar and off-putting
because it's so obviously true
yes
celebrity really matters when people are
pulling their hair out they say I just
don't know why Donald Trump is 40 50
points ahead in the polls he shouldn't
be he said some stupid thing which he
did and he did some stupid thing as
president yeah he did he did a number of
them and he he is not as good on this
particular issue as some other candidate
yeah that's probably true too
he's got it man I don't know what to
tell he's just yeah he's a celebrity
Putin called this in 2016. and you might
say Putin's a dirty rotten fella but the
guy knows how to hold on to power and
Vladimir Putin said oh it's very clear
in this GOP Primary Donald Trump is Far
and Away the leader
he just has something about him that it
attracts people to him and so if you
want to beat Trump
and I know there are a lot of people who
really hate Trump and they want to beat
him
you need to try to match that and it's
probably not going to happen because the
guy's been a celebrity and he's an
American original for like 40 years now
but
you've got to match that if you're only
a response to that to this guy being a
freaking rock star on the campaign Trail
and signing women's chests if your only
response is well sure but my candidate
he's more competent he's got the
Charisma of competence then you can keep
muttering that to yourself until your
candidates out of the race
and you can shoot the messenger if you
like but that is just a fact in every
single presidential race certainly in my
lifetime and before
maybe ever with maybe the exception
would be Calvin Coolidge
the more charismatic candidate wins
every time
within certain boundaries
within
trying to calculate for certain
eccentricities it happens Trump
obviously in 2016 before that Romney
it's not not Mr Charisma but more so
than many of his competitors
but he lost the general because Obama
was more charismatic than him John
McCain had a little more ethos to him
than some of his competitors
but even controlling for that
Obama much more charismatic than John
McCain
George W bush much more charismatic than
Al Gore and John Kerry Bill Clinton much
more charismatic than Bob Dole Bill
Clinton much more charismatic than
George H.W bush
Ronald Reagan much more charismatic than
the Democrats and then Mondale and then
Jimmy Carter and then the entire
Republican field both times
on and on and on
it's the way it works man people
shouldn't be like that okay well people
are so if if you want to run a popular
government of the People by the people
who are the people you've got to account
for the way people work speaking of
celebrities
Louis C.K who I generally like even
though he's completely wrong and what
he's about to say Louis CK was just on
Joe Rogan and he
made the perfect liberal argument
for Mass migration and open borders my
feeling is they should open it the
border is let him pour it let everybody
pour in and and then the answer which is
well then there will be all these
problems yes there should be it
shouldn't be so great here is what I'm
saying in America it shouldn't be it's a
weird thing to sequester a certain group
of people and try to keep upping their
lifespan and their lifestyle
and just keep trying to increase that
for this group of people and then
everyone's and then this pressure of
people trying to come in so they can
enjoy it uh and then it gets worse and
worse down here I mean I'm not Canada
it's really just from down here uh
there's something wrong with that that's
not a system that's working
and it forces people to do cruel things
to other people there's a lot of people
that die so Americans can be safe okay
so pause right here at first
I wondered
is Louis CK being ironic here he does
this in his routine sometimes like he'll
come out he'll do a routine
where he'll say look abortion I think
women should be able to have abortions I
think totally apps I'm 100 pro-choice
women should have abortions because go
and have an abortion it's just a regular
procedure it's just like going using the
bathroom
or it's murdering a baby
and that's the subversion at the end
this is not all like I'm with you I
think it was uh Bill Byrd at a similar
bit maybe it was Chris Rock I forget the
number of comedians have done this bit
but but Louis CK he starts out he leads
you oh yeah it's totally fine it's
normal it's like having your tonsil's
taken out or it's murdering a baby might
be actually huh it's murdering a baby I
guess you probably shouldn't do it but
here I think he's being totally sincere
he's saying at something that liberals
will often argue they'll say look we we
have privilege it's it's bad that we
have I feel icky about having privilege
and it's not
why doesn't everyone live like we do I I
actually I bet the reason they don't
live like us is because of who we are
like the fact that we have a nice life
that's not just an exception to the rule
of human society it's actually probably
the cause of all the misery around the
fact that we have a good life is why so
many people are miserable around the
world so to make other people happy
we've got to make ourselves miserable he
goes on they're just dying you know
weddings that are drone bombed in Yemen
because the guy said something that
might have resulted in American
insecurity not even like definite
American deaths but like just so we can
breathe a little easier folks die
and folks do labor in unsafe places so
that we can keep the prices where we
like them there's so much about American
life that other people pay for that's
part of it but also it's not good for us
either it's not a good way to live in a
gated community you know if if you let
folks pour in like any other wave it'll
kind of slosh and then y'all just things
will be different
I I don't know like there what'll really
happen a bunch of people like well they
just come with knives and start killing
everybody I don't think so
that's literally what happens yes that's
what happens if you look at the city of
London that's what happens they let a
lot of people in and then the people
came in with knives and started stabbing
everyone
in America we don't use knives
we we use guns but yeah that's what
happened we we let the people in and the
people are the cartels and they started
killing everyone
that's exactly what happens
how do you not have eyes Louis CK is a
pretty good observational comic I'm
surprised that he but he's a liberal too
and a liberal is one who cannot take his
own side in an argument
and so he's saying no I'd we should be
worse off I hate that we're happy I oh I
don't like that that we're doing well
it's not living in a gated community
isn't really nice
what are you talking about I've I've
never lived in a gated community
I've known some people who have though
I've been to gated communities
seems pretty nice because the criminals
can't get in and it's it's a manicured
and you have more control over your
surroundings and you can you're less
susceptible to outside forces of
vandalism and burglary and well look
would you rather live in a gated
community
or in downtown Chicago downtown Chicago
you can't even go to the grocery store
anymore because the vandals and the
shoplifters and the petty criminals
steal all the stuff so the the grocery
stores can't make a profit and so they
so you can't get groceries in the
non-gated communities
but
the the gated communities are the bad
places you don't really want to live
there come on you know I mean it's just
so awful sometimes we send drones to to
kill people What just because your
father is a terrorist okay just because
your father said like I'm gonna go blow
up Americans or something then what
you've got to have a bomb
hit you
yeah what's the alternative bro the
alternative is you allow that the
possibility that the terrorist comes and
blows you up and the Liberals
are basically open to that the Liberals
would say well they haven't blown us up
yet first of all yes they did they
attacked us they've attacked us multiple
times
but even if they hadn't you know we I
think we have the right to protect
ourselves I think we have the right to
seek our own interest
in accordance with Justice and virtue
but we have the right to pursue our own
interest if we don't who will everyone
else on Earth is pursuing their interest
sometimes not in accord with Justice and
virtue
if we won't pursue our interest who will
the Liberals won't help us with that the
Liberals by definition are people who
will not pursue their own interest
wittingly or unwittingly speaking of
taking sides I've spoken about the
American
[Music]
I told you time and time again
how much I hate to say it
it pains me
it it causes me to stay up at night or
it would cause me to stay up at night if
I didn't have a helix mattress but I've
gotta I've gotta say it
lest you tell me that I didn't tell you
so
yes or no the game has sold out at
dailywire.com shop again it will come
back in stock we're ordering more but
you need to secure your game if you
haven't already especially if you want
the game in time for Thanksgiving in
time for Halloween parties in time for
Christmas you need to order it now
because it's going to sell out and it's
going to be backlogged so if you already
have the classic game
be sure to get the all-new conspiracy
theory expansion pack in time for spooky
season and speaking of my collection in
the rapidly approaching change of season
if you are even mildly familiar with
this show you probably are aware of my
autumnal affinity for certain seasonal
beverage you know I'm an Aficionado of
the psls the pumpkin spice lattes I am a
very petite teenage white girl trapped
inside the body of a swarthy adult
Italian-American male well what better
way to bring the fall atmosphere into
your home than with the all-new Michael
Knowles pumpkin spice candle it's
wonderful it's filled with cinnamon it's
now available in our collection do not
wait order your candles and yes or no
the game only at dailywire.com shop my
favorite comment yesterday is from
Rhythm Steve who says
three minutes in and Michael brings up
the Roman Empire meme confirmed itavero
itavero
Deus vult
speaking of weird
[Music]
okay speaking of Ordinary People
becoming briefly famous
remember that F-35 that our military
just lost it was a few days ago the
military just misplaced an F-35 airplane
which is hard to lose you know I lose my
car keys sometimes my cigar cutter but
they lost the airplane and
now local news has interviewed someone
who first noticed the plane coming down
Randolph white retired from his job at
the paper mill in Georgetown 10 years
ago he lives in this house with his wife
in a very rural area of Williamsburg
County he loves living about two miles
away from where he grew up normally it's
pretty quiet but on Sunday afternoon I
was in the uh
in the bathroom taking a shave
and I heard a screeching
saw that between a screech and a whistle
I said what in the wall of this and I
heard boom in my whole house show white
says he didn't realize it was a plane at
the time so he didn't call anybody
I love America I love America I love the
American people every time I lose faith
in America it is because of the elite
degraded decadent perverse
moral idiots who run our country and
every time I have a little faith back in
America it's because of that guy
because of ordinary that guy lives in
the middle of nowhere
he heard this airplane come down didn't
even realize I don't know what that was
and oh here's what it's like ah you know
and he's just explaining it in great
detail
totally without any um
sense of
facade or any kind of you just
he just calls it like he sees it eager
to do it forthright
totally without any sense of shame or
anything like that
I really love it when people on the
right today Lament The Rise of populism
you know it's all the fancy Republicans
who live in Washington DC and they write
for all of the establishment squishy
papers and they they say you know this
populism is terrible we need to be true
conservatives we need to be in the mold
really my Junior and we need to
wear fancy ties and go to very fun fancy
cocktail parties that is who should be
leading conservatism
I would remind them of a line from
William F Buckley Jr
the so supposed enemy of populism
William F Buckley Jr who said he would
be rather be governed by the first two
thousand people in the Boston phone book
than by The Faculty of Harvard College
because that guy who lives in the middle
of nowhere who seems a little oblivious
about some things he didn't even know a
fighter jet was Landing next to him but
I bet you that guy knows the difference
between a man and a woman I bet that guy
notice some pretty
Elementary stuff that the faculty of
Harvard College and all the fancy people
in Washington DC
have somehow forgotten the rest of the
show continues now you do not want to
miss it become a member and use code
nolts in wlas a checkout for two months
free on all annual plans
foreign
[Music]